he's a businessman devised a
one-of-a-kind idea to keep his business
alive
sally jaramillo reports on the efforts
that has many vegas foodies nostalgic
about hawaii
sausage fest we started in 2011 as a
food truck
oliver knides is the owner of sausage
fest restaurant
he says what originally started as one
food truck
is now four food trucks and one
restaurant we were known for our french
toast we do a great
challah we had spam and eggs
yeah and our ban me our longanisa which
is a filipino sausage
they even make their own chorizo which
naida says
it's a crowd pleaser we obviously had
the mandatory shut down in mid-march
so we were in the midst of a big
convention
con expo which primarily 80 percent of
our business
is convention business and today sausage
fest
remains closed i was looking for
obviously a
different type of business maybe a
modification of what we currently do
therefore he came up with an original
idea huli huli which means
turn turn in hawaii hulihuli grill
came about so essentially what it is is
it's a giant rotisserie
so they put you know chicken in these
baskets and it turns over coal
or mesquite wood or chiave naida says
they are flattered with the support they
have received from the 9th island
community
and although they are primarily a pop-up
right now they have the intention to
putting the grill
in front of their sausage fest
restaurant in the near future
come around mid-november his goal to
make this room vibrant
again this being the 9th island and huli
huli being a hawaiian
food item i think it just went hand in
hand
sally caramillo 8 news now
prior to kova they were looking into
expanding the venue next door turning it
into a raiders sports
bar that is and that idea is still in
the books